The Taliban over running everything
and owning the whole
country is highly unlikely.
The Taliban have taken Afghanistan.
Afghans are thronging to Kabul's Airport.
They took over the presidential palace.
Afghanistan's president fled the country.
You don't get to lose a war
and expect the result
to look like you won.
That's how historian Stephen
Wertheim sums up the violent
and chaotic withdrawal
of United States forces
and personnel from Afghanistan.
A senior fellow in the
American Statecraft Program
at the Carnegie Endowment
for International Peace,
Wertheim is the author
of "Tomorrow, the World,
the Birth of US Global Supremacy."
A study of the intellectual origins
of America's interventionist
foreign policy.
He talked with reason about
how the wars in Afghanistan
and Iraq were doomed
from their earliest days.
And what policy makers should
be focused on as we approach
the 20th anniversary of the 9/11 attacks.
Stephen Wertheim, thanks
for talking to Reason.
It's a pleasure to be with you.
So let's talk about Afghanistan.
You wrote recently as the withdrawal
was just being kind of everywhere.
You said, you know, we lost the war.
We shouldn't be surprised
that we don't really get
to set the terms of how it ends.
What did you mean by that?
I meant that somehow a lot of people who
had favored transforming the
entire country of Afghanistan
by force and who failed to
achieve that over two decades.
Somehow they apparently
thought that having failed
to achieve that, we would
also set the terms of the exit
so that it looked like a happy scene
or something at the end.
Well, unless you think that
the Taliban are magnanimous
and their takeover of the
country is going to go smoothly.
And have no adverse
humanitarian consequences.
And I don't think these
people do actually,
I don't think anyone believes that.
It was bound to be a
terrible, a terrible tragedy.
So I think it's certainly
legitimate to question whether
the Biden administration
could have conducted
the withdrawal in a different
way, in a better way?
It's possible that over the
summer, it might have foreseen
that the government in Kabul
would have fallen quickly
and therefore would
have acted more quickly
to evacuate Americans and
Afghans from the country.
But it is far from obvious that
that is a reasonable expectation.
Given that most analysts
who I've heard from
and spoken with thought
that it would take quite
a bit longer for the government to fall.
Or that potentially there
might be some ability to have
a sharing agreement between
the Kabul government
and the Taliban.
In fact, I heard very few
people prior to the exact moment
when Kabul fell, predict
what actually happened
in the way that it happened.
So what I'm afraid we've seen
is a kind of repetition of
the hubris that got us into the war
and sustained the war over two decades.
Well, I wanna get to a
question about the US,
and I hesitate to call it
the Biden administration.
I mean, he's in charge of
it and he has to own it
but this was, having to,
he's the fourth president
to oversee this.
But what about the collapse
of the Afghan government
that we put in and the
army and all of that,
the massive and immediate
collapse of that,
does that, is that an
obvious kind of extension,
a logical conclusion to the folly of
being there in the first place?
It certainly proves the
point that it was a folly.
I mean, it raises the question.
Not only did we clearly not succeed
in the nation building mission,
it raises the question of
whether the past decade
of US involvement in the
war actually built anything?
To see the government that was supposed
to become selfreliant fold so quickly.
Now again, I don't wanna say
that it was inevitable from
the moment Biden announced the withdrawal
of ground troops back
in April of this year,
that that government would
collapse in the way that it did
with the speed that it did, et cetera.
But it certainly doesn't make
me more inclined to think.
Well, if only the United
States had stayed longer,
fought harder, this could have
been a successful mission.
What could the Biden administration
have done differently?